- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is it's possible.
Over to you, Sierra.
(rooster crowing)
(upbeat rap music)
- I hope to inspire others,
and for people to know that
dreams are really real.
You know, I wasn't raised
in this, every mistake,
every performance I've done
is pretty much happened from the world.
Or, like, I kid you not, I didn't grow up
doing singing in churches, I
didn't grow up doing anything,
but I had a dream to do this,
and as soon as I put my mind to it
and said this is what I want to
do, I wrote it down on paper,
and I kid you not, everything manifested,
everything fell in place.
So, I feel like my experience
can encourage anybody
to know that no matter what time,
you could be later on in
your time and you figure out
what you want to do, it's possible.
So, I hope to inspire.
- The difference between whether
you will achieve your goals
or not quite often is whether
you believe you can or not.
So, there's a famous Henry Ford quote,
whether you believe you can
or you can't, you're right.
And quite often what we do is
we don't listen to ourselves,
we listen to the people around us.
Whenever you come up with a new idea,
what's the thing that we like to do?
We like to tell people about it,
we tell our friends, we tell our family.
And quite often, they tell
us it's a stupid idea,
why are you doing this, you
didn't go to school for this,
you don't have the money to do this,
and all of the limiting
beliefs that come in
that then hold you back
from doing the thing
that you think is possible.
And sometimes it's out of jealousy,
'cause they tried to do
something and it never took off
for them, so you're not allowed to do it.
Sometimes it's out of love,
because they don't see the world
the same way that you see the world.
What's most important, though,
is that if you're taking
advice from somebody,
it's somebody who's done
what you're trying to do.
You know, if your parents or
your friends are the people
who are saying the reason that
it's not going to work out,
but they've never done
what you're trying to do,
their advice isn't helpful to you.
And, much more important than
what anybody's opinion of you
is is what is your opinion of yourself.
If you can create the
environment and the routine
and the regimen and
the schedule to believe
that the crazy idea that you
have in here is possible,
then will align everything in
your life to make it happen.
If you believe you're
going to go off and build
a million dollar company
and you believe it,
then it doesn't matter what
everybody else around you says.
And they laugh at your lack of experience
and they laugh at the idea
and they laugh at everything
that's coming out of your
mouth, it doesn't matter,
'cause you believe it.
And so, that's the most important thing.
It doesn't matter what the
people around you are saying,
what matters is what
you're saying to yourself.
And I get that often that's a battle.
One day you're energized
and you're telling yourself
you can do anything,
and another day you're down on yourself.
I think it's important
to be hard on yourself,
but not to kick yourself down,
but rather kick yourself forward.
If you kick yourself down,
then you're just negative
and I'm no good, I'm never
going to amount to anything,
then you won't.
But if you kick yourself
forward to say okay,
this project wasn't good,
I know I can do better,
I know I can work harder,
I know I have the ability
to make something great
and that was just okay,
and to work to achieve that goal,
and to create that environment
so that every day you wake up
and feel that that big
goal you have is possible.
Because people have done it.
People who look like
you, with less resources,
have gone on and done amazing things.
There's no excuse why you can't go out
and do something equally amazing,
except the one that you
are telling yourself.
So, the question really
today is what is the excuse
you're telling yourself
about why it's not possible?
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Linh Podetti.
Linh, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means a lot to me,
and I hope you are enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for
another shot of Entspresso.
(upbeat rap music)
- I want you to look
at something right now,
think of some major goal you want,
or maybe just one you're
already working on,
and you have experienced
a lot of setbacks,
a lot of defeats.
You've experienced a
lot of disappointment.
Maybe you've already given up.
And maybe you just need
a little encouragement
to get back in the game again.
Here's what I want you to look at:
there are winners, and there are losers,
and there are people who have
not discovered how to win.
And all they need is some coaching,
all they need is some help and assistance,
just a little support.
All they need is some insight,
or different strategy or plan of action
to make some adjustments that will open up
the key to a whole new future for them.
That will give them access
to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves,
that's all that they need.
So, what I want you to do
is think about something
you want for you that's real for you,
that's important for you,
that will give your life some
special meaning and power.
And I don't even want
you to say I can do that,
I don't want you to assume that.
See, five years ago when I
started out in this area,
I would not have been able
to make the mental leap
that I would be up to
where I am right now.
I don't want you to begin
to just psych yourself out.
No, no, I want you to be able
to say something to yourself
that will enable you to
maintain a level of integrity
with yourself, that when you say this,
even when you face tremendous setbacks,
it will be a benchmark
to keep you in the game,
to keep you moving
forward and experimenting
and readjusting your strategy,
and your plan of action
continuously looking for ways to win.
So, what is that something?
When you got an idea you
might want to move on,
you might not have the money,
you might not have the education,
you might not have the support
or the resources you need.
What is that something
that can keep us going,
that will enable us to act on our dream?
What's one of those keys
that will begin to help us
to discover the secrets to our dream?
Here's what I want you to
repeat after me, please,
with power and conviction,
say it's possible.
- [Audience] It's possible.
- That's all I want you to do
when you look at your dream,
you say to yourself
every day it's possible.
You say that every day to
yourself, it's possible.
Because what does that do?
See, it begins to change
your belief system.
See, the way in which we
operate, ladies and gentlemen,
is a manifestation of what we believe
what's possible for us.
Whatever you've done up to this point,
all that it really is is a
duplication, it's a reproduction,
of what you belief self
consciously that you deserve,
and what's possible for your life.
Before April, 1954, the common
belief, the universal belief,
because it had been tried
again and again and again,
and people felt the belief
was that man was not
physically capable of breaking
the four minute barrier,
that he could not run a mile
in less than four minutes.
That was the belief on the
planet, it had never been done.
But here's what happened,
ladies and gentlemen,
Roger Bannister came along,
and he broke the four minute barrier.
Now, here's what's significant about that.
Since that time, up to this day,
over 20,000 people have done
it, including high school kids.
What changed? 20,000 people, what changed?
Here's what happened when
they got on the track:
they knew it had been done,
and because they knew it had been done,
there was a new belief about this barrier,
about this goal that was unreachable.
And those 20,000 people
got in the race believing,
knowing in their heart
that someone had done it,
that it's possible that they could do it.
And I'm saying that if you know
anybody that had some goal,
some dream, something
that they wanted to do
and they did it, then
I'm saying that you know
in your heart that if someone has done it,
then you can do it, it's possible.
And in fact, if someone
can make their dream
become a reality, then it's possible
that you can make your
dream become reality.
- [Voiceover] In only 21 years,
Koenigsegg has come from nowhere
to be one of the highest
regarded hyper car manufacturers,
being counted alongside Ferrari,
Lamborghini, and McLaren.
How have they pulled that off?
- Well, we had to work
hard, being innovative,
and don't believe in the
hype that it's impossible.
But it's, you know, every day we strive
and push and learn and adapt,
and when you do that for
20 years with a great focus
within the group, you can
do pretty much anything,
I think that's the simple answer.
But for sure, it's not easy,
you have to be prepared
to work hard for it.